so this is how you say goodbye  you have to look after yourself not boy  of yours  oh no but we've been evicted no one  slept him here in about 20 years this  used to be my bed  it probably won't survive being jumped  on do I seem like the kind of person who  might jump on a bed a little that's a  honeycomb  do you like beats that are hives in your  garden would you like to see them you  should tell the bees your secrets then  they don't fly away stay still  [Music]  he has to understand that he must keep  quiet  [Music]  it's a small town Jane I saw them mom  and dr. Markham Jesus  if you come back here I'll call the  police  the universe is earlier did you do that  real man I won't mess  you  [Music]  you